um
so encouraging I mean in so many ways to
see just the remarkably stoic nature of
the people of Ukraine and of course
your messaging that I think is reflected
in their courage and in their
determination and in their perseverance
and resilience is just
it's uh you know it's it's to see the
children to see in their eyes
um it's palpable the anxiety and yet the
strength of the Ukrainian people is
something that is uh really
awe-inspiring in truth so it's uh and of
course you know your messaging is the
reason for that so it's remarkable to
see how you are you know holding this
country and uh and we all we have a good
country well we hold each other we had a
very a very uh I heard everything that
was was said uh today um about
um the the missing children and so on
and this is something that I think
UNICEF is taking incredibly seriously
just as the rest of the world is
watching of course president of course
you know he who shall not be mentioned
was made a a war criminal
um because of this and it's and it's so
horrific what's going on you have a
strong heart and thank you for
everything you do so thank you I wanted
to give this to you right it's um it's
written here in uh it's written there I
used to read this every day it's written
yeah Ukrainian I had it I had it
translated but I think I used to read it
when I was a child just to
um try and give myself the courage as
well but they suck with each other they
suck with cada yeah thank you so much
great honor thank you thank you so much
man